how are you guys doing in self-isolation
I I am you know it's great to be around
the family I'm grateful that my kids are
you know healthy and they're here with
me
and my wife is here too and I love all
of them I think we getting to the point
now where it's like holy cow we got to
figure out a way to not just be you know
in the house and you know I don't know
man
my kids are it's crazy my kids are
definitely looking for other kids to
play with at this point and it's hard to
explain to them you know not right now
but oh I can imagine
yeah I know that you celebrated your
birthday recently I didn't even get that
personally you just got et Canada got
that exclusive I didn't get that yes
very nice birthday shout-out to you Zach
so how did you guys celebrate during
this kind of strange time well we got a
puppy so that's the thing with so
whereas Donald is trying to limit his
his contact with his busy family we
added a new member a little baby 12 week
old puppy that we were planning on
fostering but I learned a new term on
the interwebs it's called hashtag foster
fail yeah you're intending to foster but
you instantly fall in love and say we're
never letting this dog go we had a
hashtag foster fail and are now going to
adopt this adorable rescue puppy mmm
but you know it's it's hard it's hard
like everybody but I can't complain them
I'm trying to be so grateful because you
know there's so many people out there
who are are struggling for food and
shelter and any time I I want to
complain I just go I'm so lucky that I
have a
a house and food and and I should just
shut up about anything else
I feel the same way well let's talk
about the podcast because that's
bringing a lot of happiness to people
fake doctors real friends with Zack and
Donald I love the title I think it's
amazing so your podcast focuses on a new
episodes or not a new episode but an
episode of scrubs there's 182 episodes
so what's the game plan for creating
like that much content well just for the
record we signed up for two seasons we
gotta see if we and the fans are still
enjoying this after we do two seasons
everything when someone says 182 that's
daunting
now we've signed up to do season 1 and
season 2 and the plan is to just go
through it so if you if anne's want to
watch the show with us basically we
Donald and I both watch the show
beforehand and then we make notes about
things you want to talk about that
episode and that triggers memories and
anecdotes and we kind of go down memory
lane on what was happening at the time
and then through the course of the hour
we kind of talk through the episode and
we're gonna have a guest song we just
had bill Lawrence the the creator of the
show on we just this morning enlisted
Sarah Chalke to be on episode 4 and
that's kind of the rough plan was you
know to hopefully give scrums fans
something to do they could watch the
show along with us and it's almost like
a DVD commentary if you will but but
also Donald and I are best friends so we
kind of go off on longtan yes it's a DVD
commentary gone long you've constantly
amazed how passionate the fan base for
scrubs is like it I feel like it just
always gets stronger people I need I
love scrubbing I used to watch all the
time
I yeah you know it's really interesting
when scrubs was never a ratings hit
which is amazing we've always had just
like a core group of people who always
watched the show they stuck with us from
season one all the way to season nine
and yeah I you know I don't know because
in my
piñon it's become kind of a hot
commodity because you can't find it
anywhere it's only on Hulu you know what
I mean and if you wanted to watch it you
have to find either the DVDs or maybe
purchase it on an app on Apple or
something like that and so I don't know
I think I think that has also given fans
a reason to search it out and find it
now with this podcast if they're not
even if even if you're not a fan of the
show if you're a fan of Zack or you're a
fan of myself you know what I mean
here's a way to get in touch with us
yeah I think it's nostalgia too I mean
you think about we all have shows we
love and I've been doing this I thought
oh my god if the show one of my favorite
shows did this would be I would find it
so interesting or a movie you know I
used to watch DVD commentaries all the
time and now that that's all moved to
streaming and iTunes you can I see that
they still do them if you buy the movie
but I never do it anymore
and so I love hearing anecdotes and and
funny stories from behind the scenes of
a show I loved and I just think it's a
fun thing we were gonna do this before
this this whole crisis we were planning
to start and and and in fact when this
happened we thought oh can we still do
it how will we do it from home because
we were gonna go to a studio and and
then the people at I heart told us
taught us and showed us with some
gadgetry how to do it and and so I think
for us it gives us something to do you
know we're stuck home as well and it's
it's kind of fun we we almost make a
point not to talk during the week so we
scrubs you know taking medicine and of
course healthcare workers are at front
and center of this Penda because that's
something that you guys were thinking
about when you were wanting to launch
this podcast you said a dude makes me
miss Sarah's charms yeah you know we
were gonna do this way before the
pandemic thing happened and like Zack
just said I heart showed us how to cut
out you know from our homes on the state
of the art studio that you write in my
closet they've taught us how to stream
and so
that's what we're doing through zoo I
mean we of course you know we were
planning on doing it but but I think it
does I think it does take on something
extra special now because the show is
always about celebrating the medical
community was always about giving a
beautiful shout outs whoo how hard it
was to take on this this career path how
much love and passion these people put
into what they do and their patients and
I think now more than ever there's a
there's another connection to it I also
think that a lot of medical personnel
like I hope that I know most of them
don't have any spare time but over the
years Donald and I heard so much about
how the show inspired people to go to
medical school and get into the medical
profession so I I don't know about you
Donald but part of me thinks like when
someone does have a drive home or a
moment to exhale maybe maybe they listen
and we make them laugh I hope so I truly
hope so well and last question wrap
things up what is the key to your
friendship because the show wrapped up
10 years ago now and you guys are still
best friends so why do guys love each
other so much I'm gonna say it's cuz of
my wife if it wasn't for my wife he and
I oh man the fights we've had fights
that have potentially ended other
relationships my wife always steps in at
the right time and says I'm like any
married couple we sometimes need
mediation yes absolutely
hey Jay Z gob is literally our couples
turf